[Applause]
[Music]
and I wanted to begin tonight by reading
to you a message that a Muslim girl from
France who fled to Syria to join the
Islamic State in 2012 wrote to her
mother this is a teenage girl and she
said mom you're too materialistic all
that matters to you is finding your
daughter you should know that I am no
longer your daughter I belong to Allah I
will never return to the land of the
unbelievers if your government of
unbelievers should come to find me with
an army we will execute every last one
of them the truth will win out and we
are afraid of nothing we love death more
than you love
life we love death more than you love
life is something that not only this
girl from France said but that many many
Islamic jihadis have said over the years
and that the Islamic State jihadis never
Tire of repeating we will win they say
because we love death more than you love
life and that is why it is good that you
came here tonight and that is why it's
so important that you came here tonight
because what we have in the struggle
with Isis the Islamic State as they call
themselves is not just a struggle
against a terrorist group that may wreak
havoc in the United States although it
is certainly that what we have is not
just a struggle with a group that has
made ruin the lives of countless numbers
of people in Iraq and Syria as well as
elsewhere and that we owe it to those
people to try to combat it in the name
of Human Rights although it is certainly
that but what we have is something more
than either one of those things and that
is nothing less and this is not an
overstatement than the final struggle
between life and death now you may think
well wait a minute you've really just
gone off the deep end here are you
talking some apocalyptic uh fantasy well
actually the Islamic State thinks that
that is exactly what they're going to
bring about the apocalypse the final
battle between the Muslims and the
non-muslims which they Envision
happening in 10 years in dbic a town in
northern Syria that they already
control and whether or not that's really
going to happen within the next 10 years
there is is a fundamental
choice in how human life is to be
pursued and how Human Society is to be
ordered that the Islamic State presents
to each and every one of us even now
before American armies ever get to dabic
and fight the Muslims if they ever do
and that is because the judeo-christian
civilization Western Civilization
whatever your relationship to Judaism or
Christianity may be whether you are
committed to one or the other or to
neither one the fact is that our entire
civilization and culture and worldview
is based on love for
life that God is the creator of all life
and that life is good is worthy of
respect and that creation and creativity
are good things that are valued and
ought to be respected as well and so you
see that all over if you go to Europe
and you see the
ancient Roman artifacts and they were
not destroyed because we respect what
the Romans built and what they made and
we respect the thinkers the Hebrew
thinkers of the Jewish scriptures and
the Greek thinkers Aristotle and Plato
and Socrates and the others who together
formed the bases upon which Christian
Europe was built and formed the habits
of mind and the core assumptions that
led to our understanding of human rights
our understanding of the equality of
dignity of all people our understanding
of the value of each human life and so
very much
more it's a struggle between life and
death you either love life or you love
death what we have in the Islamic State
are by their own admission the lovers of
death the Quran says oh you who are Jews
because the Quran is always hanging the
Jews and the Quran says you who are Jews
and you say we are children of God and
his beloved then prove it by showing
that you love
death now wait a minute if you are
actually children of God and his beloved
then you'll love life because God is
life and the author of life and even if
you are not a believer in any particular
religious Creed you still have the
choice in your own life you're going to
love life or you're going to love death
you're going to love creation or you're
going to love destruction and ultimately
these two impulses have clashed many
times in human history the struggle
between the Nazis and the Western Powers
was not ultimately only about who was
going to hold hegemony in
Europe it was about whether we would
ultimately be lovers of life or lovers
of death whether we would celebrate the
philosophy that could absolutely
unapologetically and even proudly send
Millions upon millions of people to be
murdered or whether we would stand up
and say that's an Abomination because
every human life has value and so we're
going to fight against you and stop you
from doing that and now here we come
again and we have yet
another confrontation between the lovers
of life and the lovers of death the
Islamic state has recently got gotten
quite a bit of attention for destroying
the Roman ruins not actually ruins but
the Roman uh the ancient Roman buildings
at Palmira in Syria and the winged
Assyrian horses that were in the museum
at mosul and elsewhere they destroyed
those things because the Quran the holy
book of Islam also says go around the
world and see what became of the
civilizations that rejected Allah what
are you supposed to see when you go
around the world and look at the
civilizations that rejected Allah you're
supposed to see
ruins because Allah is supposed to have
judged them if the ancient Roman
buildings are still standing it's a
cumbent upon the Islamic State to
destroy
them because that shows the judgment and
the power of
Allah the Quran says fight them that is
the unbelievers and Allah will punish
them by your hands they are the wrath of
God they are the wrath of their God and
the wrath of their God is Manifest in
destroying and
killing it's the love of death versus
the love of
life we respected those those ancient
artifacts and preserved them and kept
them so that we could learn about the
ancient cultures and civilization and
thereby enrich our own they only see
this is an occasion to show the Judgment
of Allah we need to create ruins these
people have rejected Allah we need to
kill
them what they hope this will all
culminate in is that final battle at
dbic now they didn't just pick dbic
which is a small town 3,000 people in
Northern Syria maybe it's got a thriving
apocalypse tourist trade by now I don't
know but there's otherwise no reason to
go there but as it happens
Muhammad the prophet of Islam if he
existed actually even if he didn't he's
attributed to there is attributed to him
a statement whereby he said that the
final battle between the Muslim and the
non-muslims will happen when the Romans
will show up at
dbic and there will be the final
showdown followed by the victory of the
Muslims and Jesus the Muslim Prophet
will return break all the crosses kill
the pigs abolish the gizia that is
destroy Christianity and Conquer and
islamize the world that's the plan and
the Islamic State hopes to bring this
about in 10 years that's why they and
this is so important to them they call
their magazine dabic after the name of
this
town
now here again they see this as the
final showdown that it's all coming down
whether it is or not they're going to be
working toward it and killing a lot of
people to try to get there and they also
have plans for before the before the
final battle in the next 10 years they
have quite a lot of plans for conquest
and murder on the way to dbic one of the
main things that they intend to do is
conquer Rome you'll notice that Muhammad
is supposed to have said that the Romans
will come and fight at dbic this is
because at the time that these stories
were fabricated the Roman Empire was a
Christian Empire and was a formidable
foe of the Muslim Arabs and
so the statement attributed to Muhammad
says the Romans are going to come fight
nowadays the Islamic State interprets
that as meaning that the Americans will
come the Americans as the final exponent
of that judeo-christian Civilization
that went from ancient Israel and
ancient Greece into Europe into the
Roman Empire and into England and
finally to the United
States and so we are in effect the
Romans and are going to go there and
fight them before that they're going to
conquer Rome itself because another
prophecy attributed to Muhammad is that
first he said you will conquer the new
Rome and then you will conquer the old
Rome the new Rome being
Constantinople the second capital of the
Roman Empire founded by Constantine in
the 4th Century Constantinople was
conquered by the Muslims in
1453 700 800 years after Muhammad is
supposed to have lived and
died now it's 700 years more or less
after that and many Islamic imams s and
Scholars and spokesmen have said now is
the time for the second half of the
prophecy to be fulfilled New Rome
Constantinople was conquered and now
it's time for old Rome now how on Earth
can the Islamic State a group of
terrorists who because of a power vacuum
in Iraq and Syria are now able to rule
over an area larger than Great Britain
but still a terrorist group how do they
have any idea that they will conquer
Rome much less bring about this final
apocalyptic
battle mind you they are not thinking
that they're going to amass a
conventional Army and March into Italy
and Conquer Rome as a matter of fact
last February they explained to us as
after the manner of Hitler and mine comp
exactly what they were going to do and
how they're going to do it and they said
that they said last February that
they're going to flood Europe with
500,000 refugees
does that sound
familiar do you think conceivably there
could be any connection to this present
Refugee
crisis of course world leaders Barack
Obama David Cameron and Angela Merkel
all the rest of them they all are sure
that of course that there's no possible
connection between the Islamic State
threatening to flood Europe with
refugees just a few months ago and
Europe being flooded with refugees now
any connection would be in
conceivable however the Islamic State a
spokesman from them recently said well
we've already got 4,000 of our men into
Europe among the refugees and more
coming all the
time even more ominously just a few days
ago the Lebanese education Minister met
with David Cameron the Prime Minister of
Great
Britain and said to him we have 1.1
million Syrian refugees in
Lebanon they're not staying Lebanon
lebanon's just right next door they're
on their way to Europe and that of those
1.1 million refugees he said
2% at least are active Islamic
jihadis that's 20,000
men that's in the refugee camps in Syria
on their way to Europe now how many are
already in
Europe how many is Barack Obama going to
bring over when he uh pitches in and
AIDS the refugee crisis by bringing them
over here
see the Islamic State always pictured
that they would conquer us not by
conventional Warfare but by subversion
and
infiltration and exactly that is what is
happening subverting the existing order
in Europe and stigma meanwhile their
allies and friends in the west are
stigmatizing and demonizing the people
who are calling attention to this so
that Paul very kindly pointed out to you
that I can't go to to Great Britain and
embar from there because it's nothing
personal the government is afraid to
offend its growing Muslim population and
they had barred a few Islamic jihadis
and they thought well this looks bad we
have to Bar some other people so we're
not just barring Muslims because then
the Muslims will be angry with us and so
they barred us and some others and the
fact is though that the more that res
resistance to this and calling awareness
to this and speaking realistically about
this threat is indeed marginalized in
this manner then obviously the fewer
people you're going to get who will be
willing to do it and then if everyone is
afraid to speak out about the threat
while these refugees are pouring in and
everybody knows that only racist bigoted
islamophobes would dare suggest that
there could be jihadis among them well
nobody will say a word and the whole
operation can advance unimpeded and
unopposed
and so it works very well subversion and
infiltration and the upshot is this a
Polish convert to Islam who joined the
Islamic State he recently said we're
going to storm the Vatican and we're
going to hold Mass beheadings in St
Peter
Square how inconceivable is it really
that that could happen if Europe if if
say 20,000 jihadis were to descend upon
Europe and make a con certed
action how really difficult to believe
is it they might not be able to hold
Rome they might not be able to establish
an Islamic State in Europe at least not
at this time but could they overrun it
could they behead the pope and many
others in St Peter Square well there's
absolutely no doubt that that is a very
distinct possibility and that it
wouldn't really take a whole lot of
people to pull it off if you think about
it nobody would have predicted in
January
2014 that the Islamic State would indeed
hold a territory larger than the size of
Great Britain in Iraq and Syria nobody
thought they could pull it off Barack
Obama dismissed them as the JV team and
even
Al-Qaeda one of the things that you'll
see in the book is that Al-Qaeda wanted
to establish a caliphate in
Iraq 10 years ago you remember Abu
musaba zarka he was the leader of
al-Qaeda in Iraq
and he was corresponding with Iman a
zahiri zahiri the second in command the
al-Qaeda second banana and now the
headman in Al-Qaeda since Osama was
killed and they were talking about we we
going to establish a caliphate here and
zarab was all for it but zahiri said no
wait and Osama Bin Laden himself put the
brakes on the idea he said if you do
that the Americans will come in and
will level the caliphate and embarrass
the Muslims worldwide Zara and his group
after he was killed in ' 06 they said no
we're going to do this and Allah will
bless it the caliphate was established
on June 29th 2014 and has only grown
since then and so pathetic has the
American response been do you remember
Baghdad Bob the Iraqi information
Minister and how he was saying the
Americans are nowhere near Baghdad and
then the American tanks would go by in
the background while he was on the
green
and you know he was he was an
international joke but now the Pentagon
a few months ago published a map saying
look how great how well the air strikes
have worked and the Islamic state has
lost 40% of its
territory and they left out all the
territory that the Islamic State had
gained in the same time period they
actively falsified the map and were
exposed doing so and recently there were
there was a large number I'm think about
50 intelligence agents who said that
their reports on Isis had been falsified
after they submitted them to make them
look better than they
were and so what we have is on the one
hand the lovers of death are actively
working by means of subversion and
infiltration to Creek havoc in Europe
and then in the United States to
overturn the existing order not by a
direct frontal assault but by the death
of a Thousand Cuts By overwhelming law
enforcement with so many attacks so many
plots that it can't keep up and
ultimately it's overwhelmed and
collapses and on the other hand we have
people playing politics and denying and
just trying to fool the American public
for their own political
gain rather than confronting it
fully and so the struggle between life
and death is going to continue imagine
what would happen if they were let loose
in Europe do you think that the
Destroyer of palmir would hesitate to
smash the David or to destroy the
Lou there's so many things in Europe
they could destroy they would love it
because that's what they're all about is
destruction and
death if we are going to deal with this
realistically then we have to in the
first place deal with it realistically
and that is the one thing that no one is
doing at this point not government not
law enforcement not the media
nobody you may recall that the Nazi
Germany was the first country in the
world to have a Ministry of propaganda
and this was because it was a state
built on lies lies and death and all of
it they all go together an a state built
on lies has to constantly
insist has to constantly yell at you and
tell you how things are because you can
see with your eyes that things are one
way way and they want you not to think
that they want you to think there
another way so they have to constantly
tell it to you because otherwise you'll
forget and just go back to seeing things
as they are that's just the natural
order of
things today if you turn on
CNN or read the New York Times or the
Washington Post or any one of the other
ones you will see a steady stream of
Articles or a steady procession of
Talking Heads is telling you the Islamic
state has nothing to do with
Islam and Barack Obama will tell you
that and David Cameron and John KY and
Joe Biden and every last other leader in
the Western World they all agree that
Islam is a fine and wonderful thing and
there's this perversion of it that's
ruining every everything for
everyone in the first place there are
30,000 Muslims from around the world who
have gone to Iraq and Syria and to Isis
Holdings in Libya to join the Islamic
State they have done so because they
accept its understanding its
self-description as the caliphate the
sole legitimate government for Muslims
worldwide they go there because they see
how everything they do everything even
the most Savage and bloody things that
they do is based on the Quran and the
example of Muhammad Muslims can read the
Quran John KY and Joe Biden read it and
they see a wonderful book of Peace but
somehow this eludes all those Muslims
who've gone to join the Islamic
State I think John KY and Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and David Cameron really
ought to give Quran lessons to all these
Muslims because somehow they don't see
what is patently obvious to all our
leaders but you know it's an adage as
old as Warfare you can't defeat an enemy
you don't understand and you certainly
cannot defeat an enemy that you refuse
to understand and this is the situation
that we're in now the mainstream media
has to keep pumping out these articles
about how Isis has nothing to do with
Islam and Isis is violating various
tenants of Islam and uh the all these
Muslims are are are protesting against
or fighting against Isis they have to
keep pumping them out just like the
Geral propaganda Ministry had to keep
pumping out the Nazi nonsense because
it's so counterfactual it's so much of a
lie it's so contrary to what we see with
our own own eyes that if they don't keep
insisting on it then it will fall away
from people's Consciousness and that's
what it should do because it is a Lie
the Islamic state is recruiting from
among peaceful Muslims and is justifying
its actions based on core teachings of
the Quran and muhammmad if we're going
to confront and defeat it then we have
to confront that fact and deal with it
realistically we have to that would lead
in turn to a reconfiguration of our
Global alliances for example every year
since 911 we've been giving over a
billion dollars to Pakistan to fight
Al-Qaeda and the
Taliban and you may know that in 2008
which is now seven years ago it was
revealed that the Pakistani Spy Service
the isi not to be confused with the isi
that published my book did Muhammad
exist the Pakistani Spy Service was
actually funneling a great deal of that
money to Al-Qaeda and the
Taliban what do you think the response
to this Revelation was in the US
Congress you're right give the
pakistanis more money and they
did because obviously if they're having
to give money to Al-Qaeda and the
Taliban out of what we give them they
must not have enough the poor
deers and so if we give them more then
presumably they will not give any to
Al-Qaeda and the Talib this of course
doesn't make any sense at all but it
keeps it keeps going on Vladimir Putin
just a few weeks ago called for an
international alliance against terrorism
and Barack Obama refused because
Vladimir Putin is helping Bashar Assad
who's no doubt a
scoundrel against the Islamic State but
if Bashar Assad is removed the Islamic
State takes advantage wins a huge
Victory and is that much closer to
Lebanon to Israel and to Europe
so Vladimir Putin is dealing with this
realistically and Barack Obama is
not and that International Alliance is
something that could and should be
brought about there are many states in
fact ultimately all non-muslim states
are targets of the Jihad now is the time
for us to recognize that and to unite
and while American Muslim advocacy
groups have condemned the Islamic
State they've actually done so not
because they're moderates and the Islam
state is extremists they've done so
because the American Muslim advocacy
groups are all tied to the Muslim
Brotherhood which has been trying to
establish a caliphate since 1928 but
they never were able to pull it off so
they view the Islamic State as an
upstart competitor that stole their
Thunder of course they condemn it but
there is not a single mosque or Islamic
school or Islamic organization in the
United States or anywhere in the world
for that matter that has any program to
teach Muslims why they should reject the
understanding of Islam represented by
the Islamic State that's an
extraordinary Omission if they really
condemn it and our government
authorities law enforcement officials
ought to be pressuring them on that
point but these things can only be done
if we have the guts to face the real the
the the problem in its full dimensions
and face it realistically and that is
exactly not what's happening now the
thing about the struggle between life
and death is that it's ongoing the Nazis
were were going to continue to advance
and continue to kill and continue to
conquer until they were stopped by
force so also the Islamic State they
have a global vision they have a global
mandate they're going to keep coming and
they're going to keep killing until
they're stopped by force we can either
stop them now it would be not a very
difficult thing to do or we can stop
them later when it will be that much
more difficult depending on how long we
wait ultimately however they are foro
I would not advise sitting around and
waiting for them to go away they're not
going to do that but ultimately death
never defeats life Soulja Nissan spoke
about the blades of grass poking through
the concrete and think about that if you
cover a ground with
concrete and the concrete is strong and
you would think the ground underneath
everything in it would just die but it
doesn't and a blade of grass that is so
infinitely less strong infinitely weaker
than the concrete ultimately breaks the
concrete and pokes
through and death will never conquer
life in the same way life will always
win
out but it is very possible and we C I
cannot uh uh ignore or paper over this
fact that while life will always conquer
death there is no guarantee given
anywhere by anyone and or and there's no
historical lesson that can be drawn that
guarantees that the United States will
always be here or that the Western
Europe will always be free or that the
Republic that we have established here
will always remain in its
Integrity it could be that the Islamic
State will keep advancing and they will
not be able to conquer Us full frontally
but they will be able to subvert and
infiltrate to the extent that the whole
thing collapses that is a possibility
and it could be that a very dark and
bloody age could follow I don't believe
that that would be the end of
civilization or the end of people who
love life the people who love life will
always Triumph but do we really want to
condemn our children and our children's
children and maybe Generations after
that to a life of nothing but struggle
and strife and
bloodshed that is what is at stake here
and so it is extraordinarily important
that we do all we can understanding that
nobody else is going to do it for us
that we do all we can Where We Are to
raise awareness among those we know
about what the Islamic state is and what
is its stake and that we' pressure our
elected officials to act realistically
about this and in every election cycle
to make it absolutely clear to them that
we're not going to tolerate this
politically correct officiation and
misinformation and disinformation any
longer the stakes are very high but we
do have the power of Life The Power of
creation and creativity and the power of
the truth on our side and so I am
confident that we will
prevail once we understand exactly the
nature of the fight we're in thank you
very
much absolutely how can you uh you can't
deal with the Islamic State and
isolation is essentially the observation
and you have to deal with the fact that
Iran is there Iran hates the Islamic
State there Shiites the Islamic state is
sunnis and so to take out the Islamic
State would be to Aid Iran
to Aid Iran against the Islamic State
would be to Aid
Iran it's a very difficult situation I
think that one thing that we can do is
one thing we never did before and that
is instead of just showering money on
places like Pakistan that just waste it
or give it to our enemies you know that
we went into Afghanistan and Iraq and
oversaw the found the the installation
of sharia constitutions of constitutions
in both countries that said Islamic law
is the highest law of the land so do you
understand what we did when we did that
the United States government was saying
you're a woman and you're being beaten
and you can't come to us for help you're
a Christian and you're being oppressed
and denied work or denied advancement or
denied good housing or something because
you're not a Muslim you can't come to us
for help what if we had gone in and
stood for our own values and said if you
are a woman who's being beaten you can
come and find Refuge with us Christians
we will protect you yezidis bahis in
Iran whoever we we're your we're your
Advocates and
champions and you can come to us imagine
I think how different the world could be
and I don't think it would be worse
because I think there are millions of
Muslims also who would prefer to live in
a society that's free rather than one
under Sharia but Sharia Islamic law is
an Empire of fear it's based on fear and
threat and intimidation and the only way
you can defeat a bully is to stand up to
it and say no more yes I'll fight you
okay but you're not going to get away
with it anymore and instead we said you
can do whatever you want and we'll
help um Roby can you comment on
something there's been a talking point
that's been circulated by the lefta I've
seen the past couple of days most
notably James Cameron uh they're all
starting to say that the destabilization
in Syria is all result of climate change
and because of a drought cities and
yeah
absolutely well it's uh
it's it's a very common idea that uh the
global warming ruined the crops and
Syria impoverished the people where
thereby radicalizing them that they
turned to Jihad to fight against their
neighbors because they didn't have
enough to eat and had they had a a good
harvest everything would be okay
now there's so many things wrong with
this I don't know if we'll have any time
for any other questions um in the first
place the Sunni Shiite conflict is a
very key part as we were just discussing
between of of what's going on with the
Islamic State what happened is the Bush
Administration went into Iraq and said
one person one vote and we'll have a
free election and I tell you I could
have made a killing in Las Vegas at that
time if I'd wanted to by going in and
betting on exactly how the election
results would have worked out because it
was it was a far-gone conclusion Iraq is
55% Shiite you could have been
absolutely certain that the Shiites
would win
55% and they did everybody in Iraq voted
along sectarian and tribal lines nobody
went in and said they have no tradition
of doing this said oh let's see who
these candidates are well this guy's a
sunny and I'm a Shiite but he's saying
things that I agree with and I'm going
to go with the vote for the best man
didn't
happen the Shiites won because the
Shiites have a majority but the sunnis
had been ruling the country for decades
from Saddam Hussein's time and before so
they were angry and
disenfranchised meanwhile Barack Obama
pulled the American troops out to
fulfill his campaign promise and left a
total power vacuum the sunnis were never
going to accept a Shiite government in
Baghdad and this was when the sunnis
started to wage Jihad against the
Shiites it's perfectly
clear you don't have to know what the
weather was to see why that
happened and the sun Shiite antagonism
goes back 14400 years global warming is
supposed to have happened because of
automobiles so you know what's your
excuse before that the cows or something
I mean it's it's ridiculous in any case
the point is is that
this is happening the Islamic exists
because of a variety of missteps by two
American
administrations also exacerbating
ancient antagonisms that existed long
before carbon
emissions and so the idea that it all
comes from that is just that analysis
itself is a manifestation of the all
overarching desire on the part of
western governments to deny that this is
anything to do with
Islam when this is ultimately all that
it has to do with if there were not the
Sunni iite divide the Islamic State
would not exist and there would not be
this huge International threat with
these people saying we're going to come
and kill you in the
streets excuse me and you will not be
safe in your own beds and so
on they're saying this because of
imperatives within
Islam yes
ma'am I wanted to ask about the um
Refugee crisis I mean I was home in
London recently and got stuck in the
channel tunnel because of it um my
mother grew up in occupied Holland and I
think there was the feeling that a lot
of Jews died in the concentration camps
because other countries weren't willing
to let them in um obviously there's a
lot of innocent people that are refugees
I mean every day we're seeing children
you know being held up the the the
people that have been dying on the boats
and everything I mean it's it's very
very difficult I agree um that is posing
a huge huge problem for Europe
um but what's the answer I mean there
has to be humanitarian response as well
does Europe just not let any of these
people in like doing yeah not let any of
them
in the
uh and I say that I understand what
you're saying about the Holocaust I
understand but this is not the same
thing in the first place the refugees in
Europe right now whatever the
photographs may be photographs are
anecdotal they're a picture of a small
group of people the refugees are
overwhelmingly young able-bodied Muslim
men If This Were a genuine Refugee
crisis you would think there'd be a
large number of Christians among them
because hundreds of thousands of
Christians have been displaced by the
Islamic State in Iraq and Syria where
are the Christians how come they're not
fleeing to to Europe why are they all
men where are the women where are the
elderly and infirm
if these are people who've been
displaced from their homes but even more
to the point Saudi Arabia and the Gulf
States have said they're not taking in
any of the refugees none the Saudis said
we won't take in any but we'll build
build 200 mosques for them in Germany if
you'd
like I get the idea you see what that's
all about but why won't the Saudis take
them the Saudis won't take them they
said because there's a terror threat
there're jihadis among them
but if you say that in Europe you're a
racist bigoted
islamophobe it's it's absolutely absurd
these are Muslim refugees from Muslim
countries and there are plenty of Muslim
countries that have lots of Open
Spaces that could accommodate them and
they are not going to those places
because they won't take them and because
they don't want to go there this is
ultimately not a refugee crisis at all
this is a
hedra the Hijra is the immigration of
Muhammad from MEA to Medina when the
first and that was the first time he
became a political and military leader
as well as a spiritual
one the Hijra is extraordinarily
important in Islam the year one of the
Islamic calendar is not when Muhammad
was born or when he died or when he
became a prophet three things you might
expect it's the it's the
Hijra it's as if Islam is not Islam
without its political and Military
component but even more than that
Muhammad's action in this enshrined in
Islam the concept of immigration as a
holy act to leave one land and to go to
another to islamize the new land is to
imitate Muhammad which is a great
blessing and the greatest thing that a
Muslim can
do the Jihad terrorists in England a few
years back they were called Al muun the
the
immigrants and these migrants when they
say migrants that's what the word means
in in in Arabic muun people who are
immigrating for the of Allah now are
they all immigrating for the cause of
Allah are there sick and weak and infirm
people among them certainly and so if
they're already there in Europe I think
they should be given what care they need
and then sent home or sent out some sent
to Saudi
Arabia anyway yes
ma'am room and mostly everybody is 60
years or older and our children are
being indoctrinated they're being
indoctrinated into climate change and
Islam is a religion of peace is there
any a
great is there anything that we can do
absolutely hear about these things you
know Bill Becker of Freedom X is back
here and uh bill is working on a
tremendous project with Lori Cardoza
Moore out of Tennessee to uh call
attention to the fact that the textbooks
in public schools and public
universities are whitewashed and present
a rosate picture of Islam that does not
talk about Jihad does not talk about the
imperatives to conquer and subjugate
unbelievers that are in the Quran that
all that is just left out
and meanwhile there are very highly
critical portraits of Judaism and
Christianity put in so that the student
comes out thinking that his own
civilization and culture and Heritage is
somehow unworthy and
corrupt and you know you're not going to
defend something that you don't think
has any value and this other thing
that's coming and and saying we're going
to conquer that's the good and Noble
thing well obviously the agenda of this
is is clear and Bill is working on
raising awareness of that if you have
incidents Where Your Children Are Being
specifically taught specific things you
should get in touch with him and legal
action may be in order or at least we
can embarrass them by calling attention
to it there obviously you know they've
been doing work on this for many decades
Islamic groups in the United States and
they have all the bases covered they're
in the school system they're in the
media they're in the academic
establishment they're all over the place
think going
to absolutely no doubt about it 100% but
you know we may all be 60 years old and
whatever but we're still alive and we we
are lovers of life and so we have to
fight for the truth in these
matters yes
sir you alluded to Saudi Arabia some of
these other
countries um and has put a lot of
emphasis on a
coalition why aren't we seeing these
other countries rallying to defeat Isis
yeah Obama has put a lot of emphasis on
the Coalition so where is it why aren't
we seeing these countries rally uh to
fight Isis you may recall that when the
Jordanian pilot was burnt to death the
uh Jordanian King vowed a very very
strong action against Isis remember that
still waiting for it
so what what is it that yeah he flew a
couple planes what is it that
uh keeps these countries from doing this
the Saudis don't want Isis to win Isis
challenges the legitimacy as a matter of
fact of every other Muslim government
says they're the only legitimate Muslim
government so the Saudis are threatened
Jordan is threatened
Kuwait Egypt you name it so why aren't
they fighting them because the Islamic
State really is Islamic because the
Islamic state is really doing things
that are based on
Islam and you know what that means that
means that in Jordan there are whole
cities where there Islamic state flags
all over the place and everybody in the
city is allied with the Islamic State
but they're in Jordan same thing in
Saudi if the Jordanian king or the Saudi
king or even the Egyptians act too
strongly against the Islamic State they
could could have an Insurrection at home
from people who think hey the Islamic
state is great what are you doing
fighting against it that shows that
you're an apostate heral false Muslim
and have to be
deposed so they've really they're really
over a
barrel um where do you think the weakest
point is in the Muslim world and where
do you think the strongest point is in
America to fight
it's what I alluded to before that the
weakest point in the Muslim world are
the many many hundreds of thousands of
Muslims who are actually sympathetic
with our worldview with our way of life
with our vision of human rights with the
idea of a free Society but they have
nobody to speak for them nobody to
defend them and plenty of risk real
physical risk if they stand up and if we
had gone into Iraq and Afghanistan and
made it clear we were standing with them
I think millions of people would have
flocked to us but we'll never know will
we because we didn't do
that what's the reaction
iny all sitting down and accepting this
you c a
picture country by country appropriate
sure European reaction to this has been
pretty much like all of European
politics lately an increasing gap
between the elites and the majority of
the people
and most of the people don't want this
huge influx of refugees who are going to
change their Nation change their culture
change their way of life forever and
make things more dangerous and more
uncomfortable for everyone not because
of racial issues or cultural issues but
because a lot of them have this
supremacist violent authoritarian
ideology which mandates that they
subjugate the
natives anyway the those people don't
have any Representatives there's hert
builders in the Netherlands who stood up
and called this what it is but there are
very few other European politicians and
of course he's outside the
mainstream as are all of those who are
speaking up about this you take for
example Sweden Sweden the Sweden
democrats for whom I have spoken in
Sweden very good group and very young I
was amazed I went over to at the
invitation of this group the Sweden
Democrat Party a few years back and I
was like twice the age of everybody and
I thought these little kids are running
for Parliament but of course you know I
ain't as young as I used to be either
but anyway um they won they they are the
little kids are in Parliament now and
they won 16% of the vote in the last
election you know understand in Europe
that's a very considerable amount when
you have dozens of
parties and it's all based the
governments are all based on Coalition
and so what happened when the Sweden
Democrats won 16% is that the other
parties every last one of them formed a
coalition against the Sweden Democrats
so they had this huge mega party of 84%
of the seats in the parliament which was
actually great for the Sweden Democrats
because then they were able to say see
they're all the same we're the only one
they're sort of Donald Trump in this
regard we're the only one who's speaking
about these issues honestly and so if
you think the way we do then come to us
and I guarantee you they're going to
have much more than 16% as time goes by
but uh I think also even the governments
and the European Elites that have
allowed this to happen even they are
waking up now and realizing that the
situation has gotten out of hand and
that whatever humanitarian component
there may be to the refugee crisis that
these people are quite menacing I mean
another Jihadi was caught yesterday and
they keep being caught now and there
going to be many more who aren't caught
but the Germans as you noted have have
reversed their policy almost immediately
just days after saying yeah come on in
we'll take everybody they're closing the
doors and the hungarians of course close
the doors and you may have seen the
video of uh these guys and it looks like
it looks like Hamas you know these guys
with masks and Molotov cocktails and
rocks and they're kicking at the at the
at the gates and all these Hungarian
riot police on the other side and
they're kicking at the gates to get in
and screaming Allah abbar and throwing
rocks and you think these people are
poor refugees who have fled a situ a
humanitarian crisis in their country
come on and you know these you see these
guys on the boats with their selfie
sticks and like how is it that they
they're they're starving and have to
leave their country but they take their
selfie
stick anyway re of course
yes yes
sir
situation infiltrating into the country
and with obviously the state of Israel
being extreme isolated situation and
being under attack what are we doing
here what are they doing from a
preparation standpoint because they're
obviously proba be acutely aware there's
one group or one country that's acutely
aware of what's
happening in the country what are they
doing
what's the B here in the United States
doing to help the state do you mean what
the Israelis are doing yes well the
israelies whatever they're doing they're
not saying and that's wise because the
more secretive they are the better uh
but I don't think there's any doubt that
the Israelis realize that Barack Obama
has isolated them and stabbed them in
the back and that they're on their own
in regard to Iran and I have a
tremendous respect for the IDF and for
Israeli military planning and I have
every conf confidence that they're not
going to make it easy for the Iranians
but in what particulars I don't know and
they're not saying in terms of the base
here I think it's more very important
that we support Israel more vocally and
more energetically than ever there's an
ugly anti-Semitism that is increasingly
mainstream and increasingly open in
terms of it not being just anti-zionist
but anti-jewish in the classic Nazi
sense and that it is fueled by this uh
overarching desire to accommodate
Muslims and appease Muslims at every
turn and of course Islamic anti-Semitism
it's not much discussed but it's very
deep deeply virent um I was surprised
out here actually there's a pamphlet uh
that I wrote apparently I don't even
remember doing it um but I must
of cuz I I don't have any Ghost Riders
but it Islam and the Jews and I'm sure
in there I must have told the story but
in any case um the uh Islamic
anti-Semitism being so deeply ingrained
and the left being so deeply ined with
the very strongly allied with the
Islamic supremacists it makes for this
uh a recr an ugly recrudescence in
Europe and increasingly in the US of an
open anti-Semitism especially on
campuses and so the only thing we can do
with that is push back and uh stand up
more strongly than ever and try to
communicate to people that Israel is on
the front lines of the global Jihad that
threatens us all and that there is
nothing that they can do in terms of
concessions of land or ending of
settlements or something like that that
is ultimately going to do anything but
weaken them in their in regard to that
Jihad and that the jihadis will never be
appeased and go away by any peace
settlement they have to be met with
strength that's the only thing they
understand and respect
two more okay yes
sirle I hear a lot of politicians uh
talking about Isis and they've taken
their eye off of the big picture of the
ball that it's a multi headed monster uh
that Hamas and Hezbollah and Islamic
jihads and the country of Iran are all
the same monster of a malignant um West
Western Haiti as you say life affirming
um evil and you hear our politicians say
well we're going to feed Isis and they
taken their eye off the ball and of
course our our stupid president is now
in Syria um turning his back on the
Russians coming on in working side by
side with Hezbollah and then Iran to
defeat Isis and we have forgotten
completely about
all it's worse than you think
the uh former head of the the former
head of the defense intelligence agency
Michael
Flynn uh he recently was interviewed and
he said that Obama was very Avid to a
arm the Syrian rebels against Assad and
he remember you remember he was there
was a couple years ago and he was very
important Assad was using chemical
weapons against his own people and we
had to fight Assad and he ultimately was
going to arm the Syrian rebels and he
did and he said these are vetted
moderates well Michael Flynn the former
head of the DIA revealed that while he
was telling us Obama was telling us that
these were vetted moderates he actually
knew because he had been given the Intel
by Flynn himself he knew that they were
Al-Qaeda and the Muslim Brotherhood and
he armed them anyway and so not only is
the Islamic State a creation of his
foreign policy missteps it's also a
direct child of his active policies that
he pursued in terms of arming the
so-called Rebels they're driving
American Humvees and firing American
weapons that we gave to Rebels to fight
Assad and they turned out to be the
Islamic State or allied with the Islamic
State or else these moderate Rebels were
killed by the Islamic State and the the
the material was taken by them in any
case this is something that is the
direct result of American policies and
it's the direct result of American
policy that are based on false
assumptions about what we are facing
particularly false assumptions about
Islam and its role in the region and so
it's the politically correct affirmation
that Islam is the religion of peace that
has ultimately led to all this okay one
more uh yes
sir is government complicity that I
don't think at all Obama or our
government don't know what you're saying
but they are involved in it are there
anybody is there anybody running for our
presidency who you think
will be on our side because right now I
don't
feel well I certainly understand your
point of view I don't really know you
know I mean Barack Obama he doesn't
return my calls he doesn't answer my
emails so I don't know
how much he actively knows I mean I
certainly think that it was a very
telling moment in the 08 campaign when
he was seen reading the book avidly the
post- American World by fared Zakaria
and that was the title we Pamela Geller
and I used for our book about Obama in
2010 the post-american presidency
because the post-american world actually
posits that the world would be a better
place without a superpower and so if
America were reduced were weakened
economically militarily and politically
then things would be much better for the
whole world and I think well look at
this all these years later sure looks
like that's the policy Obama has pursued
uh
can so I don't know in terms of the
Republican candidates I'm sorry I I some
of them have said some good things uh
Walker Cruz and Jin D have said some
good things everybody's excited because
Donald Trump stands up to the media
harassment stands up to their nonsense
and certainly I respect that at the same
time after we we held our Free Speech
event in Garland Texas and our event
drawing Muhammad it wasn't designed to
draw Muhammad really or mock Muslims or
anything of the kind it was designed to
say if you're going to kill for this
we're going to stand there if you're
going to say we you must not do this or
we'll kill you then we are going to show
we're not going to give in to bullying
we're not going to give in to Violent
intimidation because that will only
encourage more violent intimidation and
so we're going to stand for the freedom
of speech and we did the jihadis
attacked Etc but then Donald Trump came
out and said it was a terrible thing
what are they doing drawing Muhammad and
I think what do you mean what are we
doing drawing Muhammad we're standing
for Freedom what are you doing endorsing
Sharia blasphemy laws so I can't get
behind him
anyway on that note thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]